the first direct talks between North and
South Korea in more than two years well
they appear to be paying off North
Korean diplomats walked across the
border overnight to meet their
counterparts from the south and the
Demilitarized Zone they quickly
announced that North Korea will send
athletes to the Winter Olympics opening
one month from today in South Korea
officials say they're also laying the
groundwork for possible talks on North
Korea's nuclear weapons program Ben
Tracy is in Seoul South Korea about 30
miles south of the DMZ where the talks
lasted much of the day then good morning
a good morning so these two sides talked
for more than three hours which is a
fairly stunning turn of events when you
think that the South has been trying to
engage the north for months but Kim
jong-un's regime did not seem interested
now they're making progress except on
the biggest issue of all this seems you
done thinkable just weeks ago five men
from the South five from the North
shaking hands dire warnings of war
replaced with diplomatic warmth the
North Korean said they are serious and
sincere offering what they called
invaluable results they could afford the
optimism because the conversation was
not about Kim jong-un's nuclear program
instead focusing mainly on North Korea's
attendance at next month's Winter
Olympics the North quickly offered to
send a high-level delegation including
athletes a cheering squad and performing
arts groups the South acid the two
countries marched together at the
opening and closing ceremonies and
resume reunions of families separated
during the Korean War North Korea coming
to the Winter Games is a big win for
South Korean president moon jae-in who
has called them the peace Olympics in
and of itself the Olympics is not gonna
solve anything
John deloria's an expert on North Korean
affairs he says Kim Jong moon may feel
confident enough in his weapons program
to now engage in diplomacy do you see
these talks going beyond the Olympics to
something more substantial well this is
a very fragile process but I'm seeing a
lot of political will in Pyongyang and
here in Seoul that the two sides want to
make this a very different year that
they're serious about
dialogue and that really they're talking
about more than the Winter Olympics but
they have to take this step by step the
two sides have agreed to reopen a long
dormant military hotline we're also told
that the South Koreans want further
talks they want to talk about North
Korea's nuclear weapons but we're told
the North didn't really respond to that
but that they were listening carefully
Nora
incredible development there Ben Tracy
in South Korea thank you so much